- I don't want any of you little fuckers
(laughs)
to take my shit.
♪ Illmind makes it ♪
- I knew that what I
did was very unorthodox.
Against all the rules.
(hip hop music)
Me and John get hit up a lot by
upcoming music producers.
Can you hear my beats?
If you like any, are
you down to collaborate?
The whole goal for these guys
is to get placements.
- To get put on.
- Which is, yeah.
So,
basically I had this idea,
I'm like, well instead
of emailing me beats,
why don't we just link up?
Right?
So, what I did was
I created this little
event called Pass The Aux,
where
(laughs)
go to a studio
- [Gary] Yep, yep.
- You know, the aux cable
- [Gary] I totally understand, I got it.
- And so it's like, come through,
to a secret studio
- Let's put on seatbelts.
I'm not tryin' to fuck around.
- Pass The Aux secret studio location.
20 to 30 producers register for the event,
and you get to come to a studio
and actually plug in the aux cable,
and play your beat for Illmind.
And you're there with 20 to 30
other upcoming producers
that you've never met in that city.
So it kinda works as the thing I learned
with doing it is like,
it works as an opportunity
to play me music,
but also to get them out
of their comfort zone.
These kids are coming from
the basement with their headphones on
by themself,
with like, no interaction with anyone
to now, being forced to play their beats
in front of 30, 40 strangers
on huge Augspurger speakers.
And putting 'em on the spot so
the experience itself has been
inspiring for them and me.
But also too, just
seeing how many producers just want it.
- Oh God, they want it so bad.
They look up to you, man!
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know what happened?
All of us, by the way,
every single person in this car,
micro fame, people don't get it.
Anything anybody does
somebody else aspires to do.
- Yeah.
- It just didn't work
like that back in the day.
I'm a businessman.
Do you know what a 41
year old White businessman
looked like in culture 20 years ago?
(laughs)
Right?
- Yeah.
- Same with producers, right?
Who was talking about
producers 30 years ago?
- What's crazy about the events
is it leaves behind in each market
this microcommunity.
These 20-30 kids that
all link to each other
- [Gary] A hundred,
a hundred.
- They go from
having no network
- [Gary] To having a full network.
And the legacy,
you can be laying down
listenin' to something
25 years and
in the break where they're
just talkin' about shit,
I met him at this
that's the shit.
- That's the shit!
- [Gary] This line I had,
people were happy to be
in line for four hours
'cause they were
networking with each other.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- Same thing.
It's the exact same thing.
- [Gary] You stopped by?
Yeah you stopped by.
- It was a business community.
- [Gary] How crazy was that?
- That's crazy.
- Over two thousand people.
- Did the CA,
the CA music people, were they like,
what the fuck?
They're like, is this for him?
- Every person was just like, wow,
I told everyone I said,
yeah it's like,
Gary just became a Jonas Brother.
(laughs)
- That's real, though.
Yeah.
But no it's interesting because
I think these kids buy into the experience
thinking, okay,
I'm going to play my beats for Illmind,
he's gonna like 'em enough
to collaborate with me.
- [Gary] Of course.
- Or, and I can get a placement,
and then they walk away
from the experience
realizing that
it was more about breaking
out of their shell
and really also
getting a clearer picture of seeing
the type of level
- Stuff that goes behind it.
- Right, like,
wow, I have a lot of work to do.
(laughs)
- Mmhmm.
- All these
- All these, uh-huh
- 29 people here
are fuckin' way better than me.
And then you have the few two or three
that get the most response,
and then that's telling them that
- They got something.
- So, wait, you did one when?
- Yesterday.
Last night.
- Where?
- At 17 Hertz Studios.
- And it's 250 a head?
- 250 a head.
Yep.
So this is
- You should explain the drum kit business
- That ties in, so
this event is a new thing.
But I think it all started
back in 2011, right?
So, when I was coming up,
I was a producer.
I studied Pete Rock, DJ Premier, J Dilla,
you know, all the greats, right?
And so, there's this culture
in hip hop production
where you're never supposed to
share your drum sounds or your samples.
If they ask you where you got a sample,
you don't sample snitch, basically.
So,
basically, one day in 2011,
this was around a time that I was
working with 50 Cent
and I was kinda buzzing a little bit
but I was more of an underground producer.
- Where'd you grow up?
- Jersey.
- Where?
- Newark.
- Love it.
I grew up in Edison.
- Ah, right there.
- And my business is in Springfield.
My wine store.
- Oh, crazy, crazy.
- Real close.
- Yeah that's amazing.
I went to Rutgers
for a little bit.
- Yeah.
- So
- How old are you?
- Right now?
35.
- Was the U.S. 1 Flea Market still up?
Or did they tear it down
by the time you went to Rutgers?
The movie theater was
already there, right?
Yeah, 'cause I saw 8 Mile there.
- I think so, yeah.
- I'm like datin' it now.
- It hasn't really
changed that much though.
- No, but they did.
'Cause I grew up there,
there was a
where that movie theater is, that big one?
- Oh yeah
- On one,
that used to be the U.S. 1 Flea Market.
That's where I cut my
chops in baseball cards
and toys and everything,
that's where I learned it.
- That's crazy, man.
So, one day in 2011,
I woke up and I'm like,
I wonder if there's producers out there
that want my sounds.
- So what did you do?
- So at the time I'm like,
let me put a collection together,
a .zip file of all the drum sounds
that I made from scratch
and used over the years,
and just zip it up.
- Where'd you put it?
- I made a .zip file and I put it on my
- Website?
- Blog site at the time,
with a PayPal Now button.
I didn't think anything of it,
I'm like, fuck it.
- You just asked for donations.
People would take it if they wanted
to give you some love?
- No.
I was charging.
- You were charging.
How much?
- So, 20 bucks.
- Yep.
And here you go.
- 150 sounds.
- That's a fuckin' deal.
- Buy now, whatever.
I put it up, whatever,
I didn't think anything of it.
Stepped away, woke up the next morning
and I saw like three
thousand extra dollars
in my PayPal account from sales!
So I'm like, holy shit.
I see the
- Did you have a MySpace,
Twitter, Facebook?
- I had all that.
I had MySpace, Twitter a little bit,
but not really.
And then my blog, and that was it.
- And what about now?
Instagram?
- Instagram, yeah.
All that stuff.
- What are you most focused on?
- Instagram I would say,
Twitter, Facebook I need to really be more
- What about YouTube and Snap?
- YouTube I'm just getting into
and Snap I'm just getting into.
- Okay, good, good.
- Yeah.
But most of it is Instagram
I think, right, Sean?
- Yeah.
So anyway,
so I put that out and
it becomes this thing
so then I'm like, holy shit, this is real.
There's producers that want drum kits.
And so, I put volume two out,
and that did even better.
And then I eventually
migrated into Shopify
and then that just
changed the game for me.
And then just, from there on
it just became a thing and
- That's your big part of your biz.
- It's a big part, yeah,
so it's at the point where
- How do you sell it now?
- Just through,
what is it?
- Meaning, what do you put out?
What do you sell?
How many beats, how much?
- We probably do an average between
seven to nine a year on his direct one.
There's now a sister site, though, called
Kitsohard, where we allow other producers
to sell their
- And you guys take a
- Yeah.
But what we do is we use our email
which we've cultivated all these years
- Of course, of course.
- The artwork for,
do all the marketing.
- What do you guys take?
20, 50, how much do you take?
- It kinda depends.
Different producers with different
- Have different leverage.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- I get it, I get it.
- So the interesting thing about
- That's why attention matters, man.
It's the only thing.
- And it's all D to C,
and we just do everything
- The whole world's D to C,
they just don't know it.
- Yeah, it is, and they really don't.
- I know.
- 'Cause we did a couple
dollars but
- No no no, the world is D to C.
They just don't know it yet.
- Wow.
Naturally from the drum kit stuff,
I started a blog.
I had the blog but then
I started a podcast
which is just,
it's called BlapChat.
It's just two hours every week
of just music production talk.
- No shit.
- Yup.
- You have guests.
- Guests, yeah, Ryan Leslie, fuckin'
who else?
Interns, justice league
all that Grammy winning producers
- Good for you, man, I like that.
- He's crazy with the drum kit
scaled at the mid six figures.
20 to 30 dollar point of purchase.
- Yeah.
- If you ever told me you could
volume something at that price point
into that kind of overall nut,
I would have been like, cool story, bro.
- [Gary] Yeah I totally get it, man.
- I didn't expect it, you know?
And the crazy thing is you know,
very established producers like
Grammy winning producers
and all these guys
are using the sounds too.
So, any new music coming out,
you're always gonna hear
one of my sounds in it.
- It's fucking crazy.
- It's just nuts.
Everything from Bruno Mars' album
to Drake's new album,
those are like my sounds.
- Because everybody's incorporating
some of that stuff.
- Everyone's incorporating.
- And do people know,
people in the know know, right?
Like I wouldn't know but
- The people that need to know
- Know.
- [Man] They're meeting
with Dr. Dre out here
they're meeting with all the people who
- Matter.
(laughs)
- Yeah, exactly.
- I would say Dre matters.
- Exactly.
- Yeah he's doing alright for himself!
(laughs)
- He did a'ight.
- He's doing a'ight.
- He a'ight.
The internet literally came along
and leveled,
not even leveled the playing field.
Gave, gave
you know what it did?
It ate up the distribution of everything.
And then took nothing for it,
and is paying out two groups of people.
The biggest ballers
who built on top of it,
Facebook, Google,
right 'cause they just built.
It's basically the internet is
the land,
and what Facebook and Google did was
build the trains and the planes.
But, all the artists,
everybody with the IP, the leverage,
they're getting the dollars.
No more middle.
Middlemen have to bring so much value now
which is great.
Can't just sit and be like, cool.
Right?
That's it.
And there's merit to it.
The people that deserve it are getting it.
And it hasn't even started.
- You know what I noticed though, Gary,
and I want your opinion on this.
I've noticed that every idea
that I've had whether it's a drum kit,
or the podcast or whatever
it was, Pass The Aux,
they're all things that I felt like
would end up being really fun to do.
And so, my kind of philosophy
I'm adopting now is
- If it's fun
- If it's fun, it's probably
worth doing.
- You know why that happens?
It's a bigger macro situation.
Because it's fun, you're
willing to work your face off.
- Right.
- And working your face off
is actually the gateway,
it's not the fun.
The fun is the doorway
that gets you to put in the work
that gets you the results.
Because D-Rock loves filming,
the 24-7 nature of what he does
is so many kids want to film and do this
but they don't wanna
it's not fun enough for them.
You have to love it.
The cost of entry now is
you understand?
You have to love,
for me, building brands,
whether it's my own brand,
brands for other people,
other things, the wine,
it's so the only thing
I give a shit about,
that I'm willing to put in the 19
that it takes.
'Cause the problem is
now with the internet
like we were just saying
being the middleman,
and everybody can play,
there's some kid in Kansas City
who's gonna put in the 19.
- [Man] 100 percent.
Might even put in 20!
- And I don't want any
of you little fuckers
(laughs)
to take my shit!
Now what's amazing is, though,
the biggest thing I didn't know
is that's some fun
but there's so much,
that all those little fuckers
that are gonna put in the 19
are gonna get theirs too.
And that makes me happy.
- Yeah.
- So I would say fun's a great gateway to
fun is the precursor to
ridiculous amount of work,
which then gets you there.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Yep.
- I did that sneaker joint,
and then got in a car,
and then took a red-eye connecting flight
to Naples, Florida to
sell Hertz Rent-A-Car,
got the business and then
flew back here.
Four flights in 20 hours
ego getting gassed up
with two thousand people
and then humility to be on the plane
fuckin' like this.
No PJ, fuckin' put in the grind.
And then walk in and be like
please can I help you?
Have the humility to be like,
hey middle management person
in this rental car company,
I'd really love your business.
(laughs)
Being able to run that gamut
of ego and humility,
fun.
- Fun, right?
- Fun.
- How often do you
balance that for yourself?
How often is it fun
and how often is it not fun?
- As long as it's macro fun,
I recognize micro shit exists.
- Right, right.
- Tuesday might suck.
March might suck.
2018 might suck.
But macro, it's fun.
And when you get to that perspective,
you stop, you don't slow down
when Tuesday, March or a year is shit.
And that's why most people lose.
'Cause they stop either an hour into it
not going well,
a day, a week, a month,
got it?
- Right.
- So don't get crippled,
nothing's perfect every second.
The best things, nothing's perfect.
But having the understanding,
that macro, what else
would you rather be doing?
- Exactly.
Exactly.
- And then you start
complaining about dumb shit.
Right?
- Yeah.
- Meanwhile you're playing
the game of your dreams.
Little you growing up in Newark,
if you would have showed this now,
you and Dr. Dre?
Come on.
- Yeah, it's crazy.
It's crazy every time I see him.
- So that's it.
Know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- So I'm perspective'd out.
- That makes so much sense.
- 10 years ago, we would've met,
alright let's chop it up in the future.
Now I'm like, boom.
Let's put him on brown bags,
we put out content.
You turn yourself into a media company,
you can always do stuff,
always do stuff, right?
- [Man] Yeah it's 360 now.
- It's so fun.
And it's so, stakes are so high.
Stakes are so high.
The people that don't
grab this shit by the neck
over the next two decades
are gonna sit back and be like,
what the fuck was I thinking?
How did I not see it?
- [Man] Yeah, 100 percent.
- Yeah that's what I was saying.
They're ahead of the curve,
what he's doing,
he might be the only one doing it.
- I am.
- He took something that used to be
held secret, and he open sourced it
and created an API
and so he's scaling like a tech company.
Got it?
- [Illmind] If you put
it like that, that makes
- And that's what I'm doing.
Business knowledge and the ideas I have,
I'm sharing them with the world for free.
This is stuff people used to sell,
this is stuff a bunch of
losers are selling now,
and are giving you nothing.
This is stuff that I get paid
tens of millions of dollars for
and I'm giving it to
these fuckers for free,
if they're willing to
just sit on their ass
and watch it a little bit on YouTube.
That is incredible.
That's why I have power,
that's why so many people show up.
'Cause I'm giving 'em
the best shit for free.
- [Man] It's funny because I think the
biggest reason everything ends up working
is he does the podcast,
he does a Q&A thing,
he gets on Twitter.
- Love, love, love,
love, love, love, love,
love, love, love.
- He gives a lot away for free too though.
- It's leverage!
- Yeah.
- Listen, everybody close their eyes
and think about the person that
brings you the most
happiness and love and value,
you're always trying to
be around that person.
- 100 percent.
- Mmhmm.
- And all those kids that
came to my event last night,
all of them listen to my podcast,
they have all the kits,
they know all about me,
they're just
- It's community, man!
And you know what else is crazy?
How long you been really hacking at it?
How long have you been
thinking about it that way,
you think?
- I would say six years, maybe.
- So you already know,
I don't have to give you any advice.
It's just one day at a time.
Ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch
For me, this has been a
really interesting year,
because it did change.
It was like,
dodododododo
I laugh every time a day
like this happens for Boyd,
I just sit there and I'm like,
what does he think?
What does he think?
Because it really just went
(click)
you know?
- Quick.
- Real quick.
Since December, you know?
- Things are on fire right now.
- You guys are killin' it.
- But it's
30 years in the making!
Truly,
my thing is,
and you know, I think of myself
much more like an artist.
When I think about me as a businessman,
I think I'm a purebred.
I think I've been doing it
the same way people do sports and art
they give up on school and anything else,
that's what I did.
But I did it for business
and nobody understood it
back then.
I didn't even understand it.
It just, I was drawn to the lot.
I felt like I was a fruit fly just like
- Yeah.
- I couldn't help it.
I understood my logical brain was like,
school's important.
But my heart and soul was like, nah.
- I feel the same way when
I started making music.
I was like, man, school's not for me.
- Yeah.
It's hard.
- Yeah it's hard.
- Right?
- It's hard, being
- Especially from Newark,
you gotta get out.
- Filipino kid from Jersey,
- That's right, get it now.
- My parents are all about
- Education's the way out,
why do, were they born in the Philippines?
- They were.
- Yeah so like, what the
fuck did we come here for?
- Yeah exactly.
- I get it, man, I know.
This is what every one of the kids
everybody who's watching
this on YouTube right now,
every 17 year old is like,
they got the parents' pressure,
and I keep telling these kids,
I'm like, you'd better off being upset
and having issues now
because if you listen to them
and become a lawyer and you wake up at 39
and you're miserable,
you're gonna fuckin' regret it,
and you're gonna blame your parents
for the rest of your life.
And you guys are gonna have
30 years of bad relationship
instead of 30 months.
- Yeah.
- That's true.
I see another issue too with
upcoming rappers and producers where
the grind and the pressure
produces enough stress for them to
not even really enjoy what they're doing.
- Because they're not purebreds.
- Yeah, five years go by
- You know why?
They came into the game
for the wrong reasons.
- Right.
- They came in for the
glitz and the glamour.
The grind doesn't
it feels like a grind once in a while
for all of us.
But it's not really,
- Yeah.
- What would you
what else would you do?
What else would you do?
What else could I possibly do
than take red-eyes?
You know what I mean?
What else?
- That's so true.
(hip hop music)